تحول الى وزير الدفاع
يتحدث الان
وتكبدوا خسائر اكبر اكثر من 1600 جندي 28
دبابه بما في ذلك ثمان دبابات
وثلاثه دبابات مدوبه
العسكريه الاخرى بما في ذلك 79 دبابه
اجنبيه تم احباط محاولات الهجوم وتم ايقاف
العدو
واظهر الجنود والضباط غوز الشجاعه
والبطوله في المعارك وكذلك ان العدو لم
يحقق اهدافه وتكبت خسائر فادحه جدا
اظهرت وحدات فوج المشاه الاليه
433 التابع لفرقه النشاط الاليه 127
والبيئه المشاه الاليه 73
واقصى درجات التميز في المعارك اظهرت
القدره على تحمل وتم عرض الكثير من اعمال
البطوليه من قبل الفرقه الثالثه من لواء
37 لمشاهده الاليه تحت قياده الملازم
يوغيتش
وقائد الكتيبه الاولى بنفس اللواء الرائد
فلاديش
هذه الوحدات التي وجدت نفسها في المحور
الهجومي الرئيسي دافعت بقوه عن مواقعها
والحقت خسائر كبيره بالقوى المتفوقه للواء
37 البحري للعدو ورغم التطويق
اصطحب الملازم الشاب جمعه زملاء في مواقع
دفاعيه مجهزه مسبقا حيث اوقف بنجاح وحدات
العدو المتقدمه
هنا بشكل خاص ملاحظه الاعمال البطوليه
لطيراننا العملياتي والهجومي وطيران الجيش
حيث يستخدم 50 صاروخا موجها مضضا للدبابات
ونتيجه لذلك تم تدمير خمس الدبابات و29
اخرى في ثلاثه ايام الماضيه من الاعمال
الادائيه على جميع المحاور بلغت خسائر
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
3,70015 جنديا
وخمسين دبابه و27 مكتبه قتاليه متابعه
و134 مركبه خاصه وخمس طائرات ومروحيتين
و48 مدفع و 53 مسيره للاسف
تقبلنا بعض الخسائر في المجموعه
قتل 71 جنديا واصيب 210 اثناء صب هجوم
العدو في المجموعات المشتركه للقوات وتم
خساره 15 ضبابه تسعه
[موسيقى]
ارتكب نظام كييف جريمه ارهابيه اخرى
تم تفجير محطه كخفقه للطاقه الكهرومائيه
مما ادى الى اغراق مناطق واسعه والغرض من
هذه الاجراءات حسب البيانات والمعلومات
المتاحه هو كما يلي بعد عدم تحقيق النجاح
في العمليات الهجوميه من اجل تعزيز
امكاناته وفرصه يعتزم العدو نقل الوحدات
والمعدات من محور الخرسان الى منطقه
العمليات الهجوميه مما يضعف بشكل كبير
مواقعه في خرسون
وبالمناسبه بدا العدو ببناء مواقع
الدفاعيه على الضفه اليمنى لنهر مما يشير
الى نيته في اتخاذ موقف دفاعي هناك من اجل
منع العمليات الهجوميه للجيش الروسيه في
هذا القطاع من الجبهه قام نظام كيف بعمل
تخريبي في الواقع عمل ارهابي ادى الى
اغراق مناطق واسعه وستكون له عواقب بيئيه
وخيمه على المدى الطويل
بالاضافه الى ذلك
للبيانات المتاحه
زادت عمليات تصريف المياه من محطه جنبروسك
الى المزيد من الفيضانات والاغراق في تلك
المناطق وتجهد هذه الحقيقه على عمليه
تخريب واسعه النطاق خطط لها نظام كيف
مسبقا
اذا كان هذا وزير الدفاع الروسي يتحدث عن
الجبهات وعن مساله تفجير سد كخوفكا كان
يتحدث قبل قليل نعود الى كارمن جوخادار من
دونسك للحديث ايضا عن تداعيات والمواقف
الصادره من القوات المواليه لروسيا بشان
تفجير هذا السد
نعم حسن اذا ما فككنا اليوم الخطاب
والموقف الروسي اكان ما تحدث عنه وزير
الدفاع سيرجيوشيجوع حين ربط الفشل ما وصفه
بالفشل الميداني للقوات الاوكرانيه في
هجوماتها المتكرره في الايام الماضيه
واحصاء الخسائر كما وصفها بالبالغ اكان
على الصعيد البشري او حتى على صعيد
الاسلحه الاسلحه الاجنبيه ومن بينها
دبابات التي ساعدت اوكرانيا للحصول عليها
مؤخرا وربط هذين الامرين
نرى ان روسيا ترى انها استهداف هذا السد
اولا وفق توصيفها هو عمل تخريبي اوكراني
ناتج عن فشل هذه الهجومات التي قامت بها
اوكرانيا والتي كانت مكثفه في الايام
الماضيه تعطي هذا الاستهداف صبغه زمنيا
وسياقا زمنيا مرتبطا بهذه الهجمات وخاصه
حين قال
في خط
حديث عن محطه وقلق ربما مرتبط بمحطه زنويه
تحدث حاكم مقاطعه الموالي لروسيا يبكيني
باليتسكي قال ان لا تهديدات على تشغيل هذه
المحطه النوويه واكد ان منسوبات المياه
حاليا تعتبر مقبوله لنستمع الى ابرز مقاله
انخفض منسوب المياه في محطه زابوروجيا
النوويه بمقدار مترين ونصف ونتوقع ان يكون
الانخفاض اكبر وربما يصل الى سبعه امتار
لكنني اريد طمانه الجميع بان هذا لن يؤثر
على مقاطعه بما يستدعي اعلان حاله الطوارئ
هذا لا يهدد الوضع هذا مستوى مقبول بالطبع
يعتبر مستوى المياه حاليا غير طبيعي لكن
ذلك لن يؤثر على عمل محطه زابوريا او يؤثر
على امن المقاطعه والمنطقه ككل